all right i like the jeffrey dahmer
glasses chin i like them a lot
i'm not working right now
i like them i like the two on your own
you're like dangerous jim the two is
awesome on your left to two two two
two how you doing daddy i'm good how was
baltimore well you know what baltimore
was uh it's one of my favorite cities
it's i said this to a crowd i said
baltimore is like atlanta and uh
philadelphia had a baby and that's
baltimore okay and we stayed in the
laurel
uh harbor area which is beautiful it's
great right by the water yeah and they
have uh the new hotel there's the pantry
which is my favorite hotel that's where
i stay in san francisco so we stayed at
the pendery it's amazing yep amazing now
before i go to baltimore
it's a new i've never been it's one of
the few cities i've never performed in
so i hit up all my comedy buddies you
know the who's who hey what's baltimore
like
some say it's great some say it's bad
but across the board most and these are
big time headliners go roughest crowds
in the nation rough scraps i go rougher
than boston
oh yeah
rougher than boston new york philly do
be ready so i went in like oh here we go
thursday show
packed
no issues at all i'm like how are they
talking about
friday both shows great crowds no issues
at all saturday early i'm like this
isn't uh get ready to bring the video up
chin saturday early not i mean no
problems at all and i go back to
greenville like what is everyone talking
about this
these aren't rough crowds i've had a way
rougher time in freaking in new york or
boston even philly can get a little
dicey for you you know or even laugh
after some nights you know
comedy stores some nights
no problems at all
saturday late packed
packed most energy they have energy
drinking they're drinking booze so the
way the club is set up and you've been
there brian yeah we talked about this
it's almost like a mini theater it's
like lyrics so they're exact it's like a
coliseum yeah there's like one down
there's like one main state like main
area where the fans sit and then it's
it's tears like a mini so you're at the
bottom in the ceiling it's high yes
so our our opener go justin open it just
nelly open it oh and he's like man it's
just coupled to the right man they're on
the second tier they won't shut the [ __ ]
up so this other kid connor there's a
philly comic i gave him time ago hey
dude make sure you address it so they
don't create problems for me and david
he goes i got you i got you he's newer
kind of aggressive but then address it
the way you need to you gotta be pretty
strict with them so then david goes i
got this well david's a professional
roaster right he got his fame on kill
tony and that's what he does he lights
people up and he uh he's on a roast
battle show so whenever someone heckles
david we all come out of the green room
because we go oh this is gonna be good
turn your cameras on
so david says something about how
dangerous baltimore is and how shitty it
is
she stands they've been talking the
entire show everyone's sick of it even
the fans keep telling to shut the [ __ ]
up she uh
she says oh david goes yeah baltimore
and blah blah how shitty the crime she
goes it's better than la [ __ ]
loud
david goes excuse me
she keeps yelling at me and he goes you
really want to do this [ __ ] she just
bring it
well david for i'd say 15 minutes
straight
he goes stand up so we can see the ass
that you don't have turn around because
i'm willing to bet you got open-toed
sandals on you dumb lighten them up
light up the husband's big dude saying
nothing and he goes dude
why are you not saying anything he
starts lighting husband up but he's
looking over the left stage and i can
it's it's gone oh too much and i'm going
like this david cut you've done it
they're dead don't kick your horse while
they're down because it makes it tough
for me
the security comes to kick him out david
goes no no leave them i'm going to keep
going goes another five minutes like god
damn it dude but does his thing
i come on stage
they're still a little chatty but not
too bad i can still get through i'm like
whatever i'll get through this great
crowd
then i hear shut the [ __ ] up
shut up
and then i see the guy throwing things
at this guy below him stone things he's
throwing kitkat bars
king size because it's too many for just
one bite there's going to be a fight
oh fight excuse me sir fight i've seen
fights and crowds sure and you've seen
that
that young gentleman the younger
gentleman he's i don't know mid-30s the
guy that was throwing has to be at least
late 40s 50s but dude straight up big
and bigger than this guy but he's still
not this guy who looks like i called him
he looked like a guy who was talking the
guy who was talking was throwing things
at the other guy who told him shut the
[ __ ] up so find the guy so he's talking
about the girl is throwing yeah he's
going shut up [ __ ] you do something do
something
finally he hits him and hits him like
the back of the neck and i can track and
i see my eye i see him climb the [ __ ]
rafter jump up and troy brad pitt's
style in the face
boom
little crowds oh everyone's looking who
hits who the the the jersey short guy
the young guy who's getting the kitkat
thrown at him who's telling them to be
quiet
because they're such a disturbance so he
climbs the rafters
jump doesn't just walk up and hit him
the good guy the good jumps those are
[ __ ]
anthony pettis ben henderson
superman puncher boom rocks him that old
guy shoot the musta wrestled and not on
middle school shoots a shitty double egg
jersey shore for some reason a shirt
pops up pretty pretty shredded yeah the
shirt just goes flying not mad about it
that's a good idea guys shoots for a
shitty double like we're all watching
this you can't i mean straight up fight
he sprawls
beating his ass beating his while all
this is ensuing so the guy was talking
this whole time is getting his ass get
his ass what everyone's clapping
everyone's like thank god yeah while
this is going on some young gentleman
kind of mid front row
stands up and shouts as loud as he can
twist his dick off
and i go in my head i mark
well that's gold as soon as this stops
i'm coming back to that that's right
security finally gets in comedy kicks
them out and then the crowd like can we
all sit on those crazy boba and then i
go hold on hold on can we just address
who over here
in the midst of this fight shouted twist
his dick off and he's like right here
and then i was just riffing on twisting
his dick off the fight
they kicked that guy out they they kick
all of them out you know they kick him
out
and i so as i'm going through my set it
hits me like hold on hold on because i
see all the tables that the two tables
empty and i go where's the guy who
defended us and the fans like yeah
where's he i go i tell mark and my
brother mike go find him get him back in
here i think he's gone like go find him
five seven minutes later he walks in i
go yeah
i bring him on stage i'm like what
happened dude why'd your shirt pop off
he's like the guy ripped it off
and he's just like he wouldn't shut the
[ __ ] up he kept throwing kick-ass at me
man i was like here's the mvp dude i
said did you twist his dick off
but he when he walk in and so he goes
back and i go hold up who's that his
buddy
six eight giant white guy six eight i go
hold on hey hold on you you you look
like shaquille o'neal and white face oh
dude
how did you not do anything you're
massive
and he is he's like real quiet so mark
gets interviews with everybody backstage
afterwards
a big guy i won't say who is that big
ass now i'm probation man i don't need
this [ __ ] i don't want to be on video
man i don't need any of this because i
can't do anything smart
smart
wow do you have that video chin yeah oh
i got to watch this i got to watch this
but now to be fair to baltimore with
goobies and the owner there every
everybody was all some of the best
crowds i've had everything was all good
banner yeah except for this one [ __ ]
they must have been on drugs
let me pause this real quick hold on
i love this
i love this so my team comes running out
with their cameras they miss there's not
going to be another seat
this is the end of him lighting him the
[ __ ] up hey [ __ ] tell me what that
[ __ ] thinking
now let your girl speak for you you
[ __ ] whole ass [ __ ]
afternoon destroyed by dave lucas
[Music]
oh
oh
the guy was talking [ __ ] that's the guy
who threw the superman punch
that guy right there
that's gonna try to rip his dick up
my buddy said he catch me but it didn't
matter
oh my god
i try to ignore it i try to be cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is what a great show
what's this
the crowd
[Music]
[Applause]
he's a thick kid yes they're kid yeah i
know i appreciate you man
great job brandon your friends
[Laughter]
it just popped off you're like superman
dude
what'd you say
oh they ripped it off did it turn the
buttons
yeah you know you [ __ ] them up they
[ __ ] them up
well that was a tiny round daddy this is
good [ __ ] brother
this is good [ __ ]
so they were going to leave they
wouldn't let them stay
[Applause]
how big that [ __ ] guy is it's a giant
man
[Applause]
that's that's great [ __ ] baltimore
i'm in the [ __ ] baltimore kids and
that was the crab guy
that's so good man what a great [ __ ]
video that good yeah
look i want to take a break i'll take a
break i need energy i need nutrition i
need i don't want to eat all the fruits
and vegetables but sometimes you don't
you're on the go you don't have time
i'm not carrying apples heads of lettuce
i'm not i hate people who carry a bunch
of apples and fruit and and greens no
dude that's why you need a g1 it
contains 75 vitamins minerals and whole
food source ingredients include a
multivine multi-mineral probiotic green
superfood blend and so much more dude it
must be delicious supposed to be
delicious
yeah
i use it every day dude
friendly dairy dairy-free gluten-free
contains less than one gram of added
sugar no gmos i put eight ounces of cold
water every morning it's so
freaking good nasty chemicals are
artificial stuff join the movement of
athletes moms dad step dad stepmoms
aunts
comics athletes whoever i get a free
one-year supply of vitamin d and five
free travel facts i know it's a lot to
ask nope i'll do this just for you and
everybody listening just for you and
everybody out there so if i go to
slash fighter athleticsgreens.com i get
one free supply of vitamin d because you
know everybody everybody's low on bottom
yep and you love vitamin d man yeah
again simply visit athleticgreens.com
fighter to take control of your health
and give a g one a try athletic
greens.com fighter talk to me about cbd
because i know you have an intimate
relationship with it it's been very
helpful to you your family helped my son
we had the seizures when he was two and
that's ever since then i've been a big
big advocate of cbd what he got anxiety
trouble sleeping what do you got man it
works in 10 minutes but not all cbd
works in 10 minutes dude next evo
naturals it's my favorite i use the
sleep one every single night it's better
it it this is something that you absorb
way better it's got that it's got that
natural because the pills man yep it's
their smart sword technology improved
cbd's ability to be absorbed in your
system as little as 10 minutes i take it
right right when i get into bed daddy
takes in bed i'm out dude 10 minutes
later i'm out most cbd oil all right
achieves between 2 and 10 absorption
which means more than 90 of what you
think you're getting is actually wasted
not my friends at next evo naturals
right it's scientifically formulated to
deliver more cbd in a way your body can
actually use it's proven 20 times better
absorption 29 times better the first 30
minutes 20 times better absorption in
the first 30 minutes yeah next evo isn't
just another cbd company the wild wild
west cbd hell no so stop wondering if
cbd is right for you try it out try next
evo natural capsules which i recommend
but there's also gummies mints topical
creams clinically proven to be better
absorbed by your body get 25 off your
first order of 40 or more brian all
right and go to nextevo.com promo codes
fighter again you save 25 off the best
cbd on the freaking planet go to
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com promo code fighter it
was also developed by experienced
consumer healthcare and pharmaceutical
professionals all right legit next
evo.com promo code fighter
we're just lucky we got the videographer
and mark was there getting all like a
lot of footage his marks
there it is
i wish they got the superman punch i was
like because i was like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's a great thing i just
landed flush yeah
yeah
that's incredible how's your weekend
buddy my weekend
my weekend was interesting daddy want a
little shroom tech a little little well
i did a little shroom tech i did uh
i did a uh i did a mushroom ceremony now
did not tell me this before you lay down
what happened what is a mushroom
ceremony it's like a bunch of people
that smell like hummus do you get that
no no no i i am um
i am now a i am now a psychedelic oh god
no you're not yes i am and i'm gonna go
down the rabbit hole now here's one do
it again
oh i'm going deep oh well because here's
the thing
um
i think that uh whenever i have done
mushrooms but especially this time
i always want something positive comes
out of it because i i feel like i'm
pushed closer to the truth i know it
sounds weird but i think what mushrooms
do is they bring to the surface
uh your subconscious and the things
you're hiding from things you don't want
to face the things that you don't like
about yourself and if you're not careful
see i don't do drugs i'm not a drinker
as you know i'm not a drug guy as you
know i don't know much about
psychedelics i've done just mushrooms
and looking back on it when i was in
college and in my early twenties
i did like probably two a gram
a gram yeah which is like
what's a healthy dose a gram's where you
stare at a water fountain you're like
that's a beautiful water fountain but
what's like a dose that a typical dose
like average dose at a ceremony i got
about a gram but but i i went now hold
on
i went three grams i was with a really
great group of people that were season
trippers everybody's in sandals i assume
uh no not really you'd be surprised but
they are they they they are um
no i got it right yeah and so i uh
i so so and i'm gonna tell you why
people are this way with mushrooms
you better respect the power of
psychedelics and mushrooms and people
are listening know what i'm talking
about it's a little bit like respect the
sea
if you don't respect the sea you're
gonna get swallowed by the [ __ ] sea
respect the mountain misrespect the
mountain bro
so
i uh i did um
three grams which is a lot that's a lot
that's a lot more for a guy like me yeah
i was going to just chime into yes
please my perspective on dosing because
second legs are highly dose dependent so
there's this idea of like i took
mushrooms it matters so much how much
you take a micro dose might be 0.2 to
0.3 grams
and you'll i'll feel that it'll enhance
your mood and it'll make colors more
saturated right so that's 20 times that
and i would put that equivalent of like
a gram you're feeling it right feeling
it
two to three drinks taking six grams is
like taking like you're not getting
there yet we're not there yet
how did you consume three grams
it's a delicious brownie
with by the way um
these people are are are
heavily been involved for years in the
therapy space they're they're they're
licensed uh and then they're there
there's other stuff yeah i do like a
bunch of hypnosis
these are these are real professional
people with your best interest in mind
yeah
and so um
and so because i know mike tyson did it
i know jordan peterson did it i know
aaron rodgers aaron rodgers it's a big
thing right now like so it's
uh it's relevant because aaron rodgers
does and i had a long talk with aubry
marcus about that because aubry and
aaron are very close and aubry is the
one who kind of provided that gateway
um steve jobs um
a lot of people in silicon valley that i
know that are have become very very
successful and credit a lot of their
sort of like outside the box thinking to
psychedelics so i've been reading about
this and i've been you know but again
i'm not a drug guy but i i have to when
when enough people i admire who are way
smarter than me are talking about it i
go there's got to be something yeah dip
your toe in there it is i mean charles
johnson did it too but whatever right
he did oh yeah yeah yeah well the cia
experiment with lsd for a long time yeah
so i do
i go i go three grams deep
were you nervous or were you like was
your eagle i was i was like give me
three i was nervous yeah
and um but i did it now it's really
important that you enter these kinds of
things in the right state of behind
you'll be comfortable right yeah don't
have like unfinished business fight
don't be in the middle of a fight with
somebody in your family don't be you
know you got to have a good state of
mind because what's going to happen bro
is it's going to accentuate and you're
going to face it 100 and whatever's
bugging you that you don't even know
about is going to come to the surface
whatever trauma you have is going to
come
but after three [ __ ] grams dude i'm
telling you now and how long does it
take to kick in though for me for me
they say about 40 minutes for me it was
10 minutes oh wow okay i hadn't eaten i
don't know what's up empty stomach yeah
bro i started the ground started to move
it started to shift i was like oh [ __ ]
you're right here we go now i'm trying
in the beginning
there are about eight people there
i'm trying not to [ __ ] my pants
[ __ ] my pants that's the [ __ ] i'm trying
not to [ __ ] literally and i'm trying not
to throw up are you outside b where's
this i'm inside i mean it's like in a
building uh yes it's not a house system
no what did you notice in your brain
like what was because people said like
you start to notice that do you have any
subjective experience of i felt good i
felt bad i felt this so at first i i
thought oh boy i don't know how to
handle this because i'm seeing shapes in
the ground move you're a little scared
you know in the movies when they show
you what a trip is a kaleidoscope that's
what i start to see yeah a little bit
like dmt
but it just kept going
so i'm like oh this is a this is a ride
right now and i i was i was like don't
resist it try to relax
all of a sudden
uh uh i'm in heaven i'm inside a genie
bottle there's a genie in front of me
who's taking me on a ride you're in
heaven in a genie bottle i mean i'm in a
genie bottle and it's heaven okay i've
never felt better oh well uh the the i'm
in i'm in a secret it's a secret place i
mean i'm you know a secret genie you
know avatar yeah i was an avatar but in
a genie bottle but in a genie bottle but
i was you're happy i beyond happy
i was blissful yeah and not only that i
was like oh well this is what
everybody's been talking about this is
the secret yeah okay
and
and the music is playing and all i know
is i'm at one point i'm i'm walking
through the desert with this amazing guy
this woman who then starts to dance is
she hot
she was the most beautiful creature but
everybody was beautiful
well in my experience everybody was
beautiful and and and wonderful the men
and the women everybody's beautiful
it's bi it's it's beyond that it's like
you're just like
overly blissful you're like the
hunchback guy in 300
yeah remember when they converted him
yes he's like surrounded by dime pieces
yes
and so so i'm i'm so overwhelmed with
the the experience and the beauty but i
i you go out of consciousness you go
into these you go blind for a while and
and you're you're you're seeing shapes
and you're listening to music and you're
just and then the music stops and you're
brought back into the circle by the
guide you're brought back into it and
you're like and at one point i was like
i was like
dude and i'd go like this i would say
some [ __ ] everybody started laughing
because i because i was like maybe is
everyone around you on it too yes okay
so at this point i'm going i'm going
oh i wouldn't when i went i went oh my
god did anybody else feel what that
carpet ride was about everybody started
right yeah because dude it was beyond
anything i've ever experienced by far
bar none and impossible to express okay
because you have to be there
so
at one point
i now decide that my heart has been
opened
there's a door to my heart that's open
are you crying my buddy crying
with joy
crying with joy tears yeah dude it's
embarrassing
it's embarrassing keep going i'm no
judgment and my buddy's teeth are so
beautifully white and i look at him and
i go you want to kiss him i go
congratulations and my other buddy's
head got super small and i go i'm sorry
i meant to say that's your head's really
small but i went i'm sorry i think i
said that
and then i'm invited to take
more medicine
why
because that's part of the journey and
if you are a seasoned tripper you're
invited to do whatever you're not season
tripper no and daddy went back in for
another three
now we're at six yeah anybody can tell
you including aubry that
that is uh that's a hero's dose five's a
hero's dose five for the most courageous
and sixes old inexperienced guy who
doesn't drink or do drugs i go six
and i'm not going to get into what
happened but
i ended up going from heaven
to hell oh no and what did you get into
it aubrey told me that you get into a
hell zone i died twice and i was in did
you die eternal loop how did you die i
just left my body i dissolved so i was
like i'm dead so now i'm now everybody
around me who was this angel turns into
a demon okay and they're keeping me from
my children check please and i'm trying
to check this you can't i'll get off the
ride now there's no one to complain to
i'll get off the road you can't see all
you can do is try i kept you know how
you're like i gotta get dov davidoff
tells the story about how he was in the
back of a cab and he and he realized he
was trapped inside a computer
it's like i'm inside a computer and i
can't get out and he started crying like
a black mare movie yes dude
so i was in eternity i was caught in an
eternal loop and i couldn't get out do
you want to tell people that you were
farting uncontrollably
can we tell them that there was some
stuff three songs apparently spitting
and farting and screaming cuss words
that's all i'm going to say i don't want
to get i want to respect loud space yeah
loud farts but which is hilarious to me
yeah i apparently i was pretty i should
get a text from brian how'd it go goes
dude i was in the field position i think
i was doing that but you don't know you
don't know what you're doing i bet
you're farting but you don't know you
don't remember anything you do not know
anything i'm telling you you don't you
go blind i was told what happened you
only remember certain things yes so then
i the perspective of the demons and all
that you remember that stuff yes but i
went back because i was so embarrassed
and mortified i went back to these these
people and i said i'm i'm sorry i had
this this i had to have this that you
had this closing thing which i was very
important you have to have context and
this this guy's so wonderful because he
goes hey dude hey dude
everybody who's been through this [ __ ]
knows what that is and has been through
it themselves so whatever you're
embarrassed about whatever yeah man me
too
been there
and and so whatever the case you know
without going into too much detail
because i want to respect their their
the
you know i want to respect the [ __ ]
space but um it was the scariest thing
i've ever been through i went from
heaven to hell and uh and and i just
know now that we should stay let's stay
at three let's stay at two and three
grams we don't need six we don't need
six bubba i feel like no one needs some
size and everyone who's done mushrooms
knows what i'm talking about has has
been to that
that
hell realm i had deep talks with aubry
because aubry's been he's gone you're
saying after this though you called it i
called him
and he's like oh i've been there i've
been to the hell i've been to the those
those doors to hell open up you better
be [ __ ] careful because if you're not
ready for that and you can't accept
what's going on you're gonna get caught
in what you would you're gonna think as
hell and my other buddy thought he was
in hell too and he ran away now is
everybody farting
i don't know you don't know what happens
you don't you will not remember if you
take that much you don't know what you
said how did you feel
i felt not so good really raw
[ __ ] raw like your body was tired yes
dude raw but um
but i'm interested in
knowing what's there and i'm interested
in
i want to touch what other people are
talking about don't do this all the time
but if you're going to do drugs i think
psychedelics might be how long but
people do it how often do they do it
all the next time i i i i say this i say
yeah ideally because yeah you don't want
to be doing it it's so intense that you
don't like it and if you do it every day
tolerance builds up super quick oh wow
yeah because for me what i'm starting to
see is that that i understand why
there's so much reverence for this [ __ ]
like they don't [ __ ] around like if
you're gonna take three grams that
shit's done with a bunch of ceremony and
i think the ceremony a little bit like
how aubrey took us through dmt yeah it's
like there's a ceremony to that [ __ ]
like meaning like you you need context
and you need to be safe in this space
because if you're not
trouble
here's my question to you
[Laughter]
what happened
have you done mushrooms i've done it yet
oh you have yeah have you gone deep
no do we just i took like a
like this one i need you i need you to
come with no absolutely nothing no no no
i need you no i'm not doing it dude i
got i wanted i just you know what you
know my thing i i like hearing your
experience on it i just have no desire i
literally don't have any desire to do it
can you just do like two grams no no
my thing i'm open to drugs and i you
know especially aaron rodgers he's such
a beast yeah you should probably double
the dose in the playoffs but um i think
uh i've i just i have no desire to do it
why don't you micro dose it i just don't
want it i've i've microdosed it and went
to yoga it was cool it felt cool yeah i
just don't i have no desire like it's
not interesting to me yeah like it never
was to me either because i was never
getting balls deep i just never was into
the drug thing i know aubry's into it
well i just think that psilocybin helps
like it's got an 80 cure rate for
smoking
it's helped people with tf ptsd it helps
people at the end of their life when
they're facing a terminal uh diagnosed
cancer diagnosis so i i wanted to see
what was there and i believe that
there's something there i'm an advocate
of it i think it's good especially if it
helps people yeah never that guy i don't
like coke i don't like booze i don't
think anything positive comes out of
that stuff i'm not a weed guy i'm not
even a psychedelic guy necessarily but i
i have great deal of respect for it
because there's i i want to see what
acid is about i want to see what that
you know if you're young and you're
listening to me i'm not yeah
you may you may think i'm setting a bad
example i don't know if we're going to
get flagged for no no it's just your
experience yeah i don't i don't think
you need uh let me say this about drugs
and psychedelics i do not believe if
you're a young person trying to make
sense of your life i don't think you
need to do this i think that there's a
lot of value i think most of the value
gained in life is through sobriety and
hard work and all the things you're
taught be ethical be honest hard work
get good at something i don't think that
you need to be going into this blissful
state um
but there's that documentary on netflix
called how to change your mind that
michael pollan did talk to all those
scientists they did these [ __ ]
experiments with those high-level
science you see that where they with lsd
they had these high-level mathematicians
and scientists working on really big
problems had them all do a dose of lsd
and they all solved the problem it out
yeah because you're throwing it outside
the box yeah
so so uh i think there's a huge
advantage to it that's what steven jobs
said he said i never would have come up
with the apple idea and a lot of writers
a lot of like aldous huxley and and the
guy who created uh alcoholics anonymous
he he said i saw god when i did pcp i
mean uh when i did [ __ ] lsd when i
did lsd i saw god so lsd uh acid you you
cannot overdose on it and it doesn't
it's remarkably untoxic for your body
they've done all the studies so you
could do as much as you want now you
might go to hell you might have a crazy
trip it might be too intense but if you
do it but it still would never kill you
it can't alter your state of mind though
because that was the experiment yes
right if you if you have mental illness
and you're you're a schizophrenic though
it can trigger a psychotic event you
have to be careful yeah but but but i
think it's interesting after listening
to jordan peterson other people talk
about it who are really smart
that the the idea that a lot of
psychiatrists that are finding a lot of
benefits in mental health
so anyway i just i'm i'm going down that
rabbit hole yeah
i'm exploring the uh the first time i
did mushrooms it was i did half an
eighth an eighth it's 3.5 grams pretty
strong still at 1.75 grams i have been a
full-length so you basically almost did
two eighths which is
a lot lighter it's a lot and you can
feel it on like if i was introducing it
to somebody i would say take point five
or a gram so you can kind of dip your
toe into this experience and many people
don't need to go higher you know i
didn't think it was helpful i i don't
think six grams was was was it made no
sense because i don't remember you can't
i went into a bit of a psychosis i went
into i went blind too much yeah i just
went
i went into another state where i had no
i don't even know i don't remember
anything i don't remember i remember
tiny flashes of things yeah about them i
remember going home going to bed my girl
came and got me
my girl came and got me out of there and
then i was still
totally i wouldn't let go overhand
because i thought she was an illusion
i was tripping that so my little brother
did roughly the same dose maybe a little
bit more and he said for three hours he
thought he was spider-man like spinning
webs through like a psychedelic tunnel
you know just like
that
but it's probably like he didn't have it
wasn't bad necessarily but you will see
she was extreme and she definitely had
been a safe environment i saw my mother
and my daughter's face on another
woman's face that she just kept
transforming and that was too much for
me but you do see some [ __ ] where you're
like well i don't know how to handle
this yeah i don't know how to handle
this ladies and gentlemen was there any
takeaways from it
yes
yes the takeaway is that um whatever
you're dealing with will come to the
surface and you you will you will
deal with it
you will deal with it in one way or
another you will you you will have a
profound experience at some point where
you will be
keep doing it yeah and when you come to
you will you will want to
uh reconcile a broken relationship
reconcile something you haven't lived
down take responsibility for the
condition you're in you're gonna that's
been my experience with it and
and i have talked to a lot of people who
said the same exact thing that's good so
there's something positive about that
under the right dosage that seems to
force you to confront
things you're not confronting when you
are because we can distract ourselves oh
yeah life yeah i'm not a therapy guy i i
probably could use it obviously
i've not been to it i like therapy yeah
but i always had this arrogant you know
i'm arrogant sometimes i'm an arrogant
fool like we all are and i really am
that i'm not being a dick i'm saying
i'm sometimes i'm an arrogant fool one
of my arrogances is the idea that i
never needed therapy that i had it all
together because i'm happy yeah and it's
not true no you know it's not true yeah
we all have trauma we all have we all
have um
uh we're we're we are wrecked by we have
a wreckage to our past and you better
[ __ ] come to terms with it or you're
not going to be a fully realized person
yeah this is heavy [ __ ] but i'm just
i feel like the next one
um
i'll let you know
i need some time
yeah a few months but at least i had the
worst trip ever and i'll never do that
yeah but it's almost like you could do
it quarterly like i've heard of people
who do that it's like every quarter
every season or whatever and that sounds
like a good time frame to me you call
him up he's like look who's bad yeah a
lot of people who are suicidal microdose
acid like to do one day on two days off
and and according to this documentary
with michael pollan uh it's it's a
lifesaver that's good yeah
it's a great mood and answer it comes
from the fungus off a rye
the rye plant that a swiss chemist
isolated
literally
he's a swiss chemist he isolated it and
he got some on his fingers
and touched it to his tongue and as he
was riding home on his bike he was like
holy [ __ ] that's crazy everything is so
beautiful everything is so incredible
that's and i was just gonna say the
introductory feeling before any of this
visual stuff you go
damn that tree is beautiful these waves
are incredible why don't go to the beach
more and as you were saying before with
the something comes to the surface it
doesn't have to be i've experienced that
of like i need to reconcile this
friendship but i've experienced it and
been around people who go
damn my family's so important to me or
something like that right where you you
it makes it clear because you get busy
everything becomes flattened i call my
these are all equally important i got it
the next day yeah the only thing that
matters is this i had to talk to my
daughter and tell her how i felt about
her yeah yeah that's it and that's a
pretty common experience it is right is
it yeah like like you you come out of it
i can put that picture from my body to
me being like we finished it was like i
need to call my wife right now you know
well i don't i think all of us don't
want anything we
haven't said you don't you don't want
regret you don't want if you are if you
created any kind of distress to anyone
in the world you want to make it right
yeah and i think if you don't then
that's a problem you don't get away with
it do you
you know you and i always feel that way
about any kind of like broken
relationship
you know what i mean that you're just
like [ __ ] man i don't like this it's
heavy i don't like it man i don't like
conflict i don't like that i was i made
other people feel bad i hate it yeah and
i and that really bothers me and i don't
have a problem calling people up though
i don't mean that's for that
enlightenment
you're good at it yeah
what's going on man
yeah so anyway
[ __ ] man
well
so we took some of your nicotine patches
earlier brendan and we actually infused
them with
i start farting
you and i did the dmt i think i need to
get you into the shroom yeah why would
you do dmt like why would you be i
wouldn't do dm i'm not attracted oh but
you did it i thought you said you no
desire to do it again oh okay zero
design i thought you wanted i'm all good
when someone says they don't want to do
drugs they go all right i yeah
i'm just i just i yeah i respect that
though
i'm good i respect i see a therapist so
what made you want to do dmt in the
first place then it was we were kind of
friends aubrey was like man would be fun
45 seconds
i'm not into spending hours with doing
this
that's scary i have no desire that's
what i think is when's brendan going to
make time for this you have no desire to
block out that yeah you have no respect
yeah but by the end i don't i mean if it
works for brian or works for [ __ ]
roger except for the playoffs dude do it
yeah well i didn't read that article i
need to read it
uh it was a interview well it wasn't
even an interview it was a uh
uh aaron rodgers did a podcast with
aubry marcus just talking about how
great it was for him and you know helped
him out with so many things and he's
been doing it for like three years i
think with aubry yeah so aubrey was all
over espn because they had to quote his
podcast he said aubry marcus podcast and
so
yeah yeah man i had a really good time
with aubry he came to my show in austin
i really yeah it was a great time great
guy and i had a long talk with him he
helped me kind of navigate what the [ __ ]
was going on yeah you would know here's
his black belt now and he's got friends
that have gone
so deep like he's got friends that have
gone to 30 grams of mushrooms now that's
beyond
and you'll go like you'll go so deep
into a bad place
yeah yeah yeah that's not good yeah but
even roger's talking about i think you
know i think it's good yeah you know but
even uh
you know in sports if it helps in roger
i would assume more guys start to do it
he's so elite and if it opens up his
mind you gotta be open-minded i would
say be careful if you're not so big like
me if you're not if you're not a
seasoned drug guy if you don't
you don't drink and you have a fairly
clean body
i think you know these strains something
and there are different strains and some
are stronger be careful because we'll
start slowly you want to do it start
swallowing you gotta go with experts
who's gonna start you off the right way
start slowly like aaron rodgers didn't
start off with [ __ ] six grams or that
daughter yeah no it's helped him out so
it helps him keep doing it even aubry
said six grams is i've only done that's
the most i've ever done and i was like
oh well if you
and he's bigger and that's his thing
it's also his thing and you said you
develop a resistance to it a little bit
pretty quickly yeah so there's it's a
it's a hard drug to abuse and that's why
i don't feel that bad
talking about it and going maybe this is
something you want to try because
you know it's not physically or
psychologically addictive the reason
being you don't get out of a mushroom
trip or an lsd trip and go i want to do
that again right now you're like it's
like getting off a yeah a ride and
you're like ooh i need to rest i need
three months all the stuff that just
happened and so but i will say this i
know you said you felt bad the next day
i've never had a hangover from and maybe
that's different from a alcoholic ever
but maybe i just felt maybe yeah no
you're sort of exhausting right it's
like
something that's brilliant you've never
saw a therapist or anything people even
go through your whole ordeal the divorce
you've never stopped therapy see if
nobody to talk to get it
to navigate but i like therapists
because they their unbiased opinion than
the professionals they do like my trauma
they've dealt with way worse so they're
like dude dude yeah so it's an outside
perspective to help you navigate through
all that stuff to make you come to a
conclusion i should at least do better
help or something because i just don't
have anybody to talk to because guys
like i i even write about this in my
special i'm like we guys are not like
that i can't call you really and we're
all busy i mean we could talk but what
are you going to say i'm not going to
help but i'm not the guy to go too talk
to a [ __ ] professional i know it's
like calling me you know if you have a
you know a joint problem like get that
call doctor that's right
i mean i can tell you what i did but
i've talked to somebody who knows the
hell i went to one guy who was very much
about yeah for a little bit who was uh
yeah who who was kind of talking he
would get me to feel it physically
and and acknowledge the my physiology of
what i was going through and honor that
but i don't know if that but i think too
like some like with therapists like
people they it's not for me we didn't
get with the right therapist like you
can go through a bunch of them until you
find one that works yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah betterhelp.com promo code fighter
yeah exactly this is a whole better help
commercial everybody yeah yeah you know
like do shrooms or do they do mdma ptsd
therapy where you're sitting with
somebody talking through it who's sober
sure as you do 50 million now ayahuasca
is a different thing right that's the
big boy well again because i know theo
did that yeah yeah but again it would be
really beneficial maybe but a lot of
times ayahuasca can have like there are
people who are like i'm the devil and
it's like what and or you know it can
[ __ ] with you it can make you [ __ ] your
pants right there and throw up
everywhere shoot your pants on ups
whatever yeah
but remember that you can have bad trips
on ayahuasca bad trips but remember the
big uh like
wives tale or whatever rumor with lsd or
acid was something when you were growing
up as kids someone took too much and
then thought they were an orange and
peeled their skin yeah all that [ __ ]
scared me straight yeah
i think the deer program started that's
information
i'm out peeling my skin it's exactly
what i'm out that's what it sounds like
bath salts or meth or something yeah but
like
chin and i were talking before and he
says i'd do mushrooms i wouldn't do lsd
i used to have that attitude too
because the mainstream narrative on it
for whatever reason there's all these
rumors that it's really bad or intense
or these books i think lsd i think
charles manson i think of uh the
unabomber right those weird experiments
but so when i think of lsd versus
mushrooms
it's almost quite difficult to
articulate the difference in experience
between them because they're really the
same like they're they're much more
similar than they are but isn't lsd uh
artificial chemical
uh yes shrooms is natural right but the
the chemical molecules if you're if you
were to look at it they're pretty
similar and they both come from the same
plant and what i asked about uh your
happiness they come from a plant but
they could both come from a fungus one
comes from a fungus on the right planet
i thought lc didn't i thought lsd was
artificially known
well it is but it but it's distilled the
same molecules from a function it's a
similar very similar molecule and it
looks like serotonin and that's why they
say it binds to the or agonizes the
serotonin receptors so part of this
experience is well-being like you said
you were in heaven to start yeah
part of the realizations are or why it
works for ptsd is you go everything's
okay
and i can now think about a memory
without the baggage of intense stress
yeah and this other psychiatrist said i
realized that i wasn't just this
person that i identify as there were
other dimensions to my
my personality and my very existence and
the thing i call myself yeah like when i
saw those different dimensions it
changed everything for me and steve jobs
said something to that effect too yeah
yeah i think different
came from his experience too bad to make
steve jobs nicer right
well i don't know yeah is there no drugs
for that right
yeah it lowers latent inhibition i
remember hearing that word
like the things that our brain normally
tunes out right you're at all these
different levels because they're like we
don't need this we don't need this
ideas about yourself and whatever
rigidity in your mind helps you in a lot
of scenarios elon musk i think he was on
the full send podcast to ask him about
smoking weed he's like man a lot of
people don't realize the repercussions
that had he said i'm not a weed smoking
he's like and to be honest he goes i
don't advocate weed smoking i don't
think it's beneficial to my workers i'd
be pissed if they used it he wasn't you
know i just took that one hit and he was
and then after that because
yes it's legal in california it's not
legal everywhere because of the
businesses i have he goes i got drug
tested every day for the next like six
months he's like then also the backlash
for my employees because they're not
allowed to do it he's like i have to
apologize to him wow because he was like
i don't think weed
uh helps uh productive
importance it doesn't for me i'll tell
you me neither i'd be pissed if
someone's high in here all the time and
also people use it differently because
people tend to slip and if you're
get into it you smoke i know people who
smoke every day all day they do and
they're just numb to the world they want
to like to your point they want to face
whatever they're dealing with so you're
not doing you're not doing a weed
ceremony you're doing daily but again
for some people like rogan swears but
for rogan it's made him calmer nicer
when he's high you know so yeah i don't
know i i'm i don't mind if it works
definitely outlier yeah if it works for
you do it i don't give a [ __ ] yeah yeah
so you're not hurting anybody yeah
now i don't think they should have
needle zones in la and new york we can
take meth and [ __ ] heroin
well the idea behind that is what zurich
said in portugal it's like you create
not only a place for drug addicts where
you want to do drugs do it over there
but also by the way if you want a an
apartment and if you want uh the goodies
and not go to jail you can't just do it
illegally there are very specific places
you can do it and if you want this you
got to get sober like now we can watch
you and we can help you with treatment
and with treatment comes uh
it's carrots needles so all that
spreading disease and all that [ __ ] so i
get the point of it so the idea would be
but but the idea always when they
legalize that [ __ ] in portugal and
zurich is that there is we're doing that
so you can ultimately get sober [ __ ] off
yeah it's not like the tenderloin
district where you just let people get
high and die [ __ ] that the idea is if
you really want to do this well we know
you're gonna do it so you can do it in
an opium den where you guys are all
[ __ ] up or you can do it under very
under government-controlled
circumstances and we will do our best to
get you off it and track you and track
you that's the way
and and and get you back into being a
productive member of society because i
don't think there's anything productive
about [ __ ] heroin cocaine or even
alcohol don't knock it till you try it
daddy yeah
open my vein baby but i had something
else i wanted to talk about why buddy i
don't know but drugs no more drugs yeah
no i can't just a drunk guy now just
yeah i love this podcast because i can
be honest we'll just talk [ __ ] it i'll
get criticism i'll get support it
doesn't happen
i'm just i don't know who critics i mean
yeah i don't think anyone's gonna
criticize you for trying trooms i'm just
doing i mean and now if you get a
convertible yellow corvette now i would
say this is a mid-life price
have you pulled up 98
c4 corvette i'd like well now we have an
issue right we got an issue right now we
got an issue no we're in this shoe okay
you're doing drugs you're wearing
bandanas you need your hair done yes
right yes you're shopping at freaking
john varvatos you're a convertible
yellow corvette can't do it can't do it
it'd be awesome though a little much
my girl was getting her nails done you
walk around thinking you're younger and
the
the korean woman very loudly said oh he
old he is very old
you you you so young with you why you so
with some so oh
he's good you know he's good
but if he doesn't gamble and he's nice
to you then you stay with him but he's
all i was like hey i can [ __ ] hear
you
an english teacher he oh yeah he but he
could give you money and he doesn't
gamble and he doesn't have other
girlfriends he's good my husband always
gambles you oh big dick i'm like [ __ ]
right there i'm like hey
you know i thought i looked a little
younger you ruined my whole [ __ ] day
he oh he oh
i can't hear you yeah yeah yeah could
you i at least speak mandarin chinese
when you call me old
dude why chose run out of ingrown
toenail my girls like tell you just
gotta get a pedicure let's get they can
get rid of your ingrown toenail and i
come they're just talking [ __ ] in
chinese oh my god oh
and i could hear it then oh big toe big
toe into your mouth massive toe massive
toe but they took care of it yeah i mean
they grinded the [ __ ] they were probably
talking about you're such a big guy they
were like i wonder what i wonder if his
dick matches his body another laugh on
my foot because it didn't really fit in
the thing they're like
i was like all right [ __ ] just because
you're just taking the freaking ingrown
toenail man they did though yeah it was
great it felt nice yeah
tells you my thing's facials i haven't
got one in la though i love facials man
do you oh facial not i can't i like it
in the face
i really hate i hate my feet to be
enough my wrists my hands you like daddy
oh my god and your hands oh
hands face
all
just when i get stressed i'm always
tense like this
like my girl
i'll be watching tv i'll be we'll be
watching love island i'm sitting there
like this
like i'm [ __ ] uh the anteater cartoon
that meme remember he's always ready to
go i'll be walking on clint's fist like
this just help me hit my hand on my
interest i don't even notice i do that
too oh it's
my left hand i hold like this oh both of
mine huh
stress i don't want this you haven't
picked up your invisalign yet i have not
but i'm in town now for a while well i
leave town next week but still i'm in
town for the most part what you're going
to do is wait until the that's right
doesn't work and then you have to get
graphs 100 that's good
that's going to be good that'll cost a
hundred thousand dollars 100 yeah right
that's how i work and you'll be in crazy
pain yep but or you could just go get
invisalign you could just drive
literally 10 minutes
well 10 minutes from here five minutes
from my house i could walk so you could
just do that no i'm going to do i
promise i'll get back from montana next
week it's making first thing i do i'm
going to go no they called me too they
keep calling daddy's going to bora bora
on tuesday you know that tomorrow
tomorrow yes yeah we know that
so daddy won't be around and then you go
to montana the following week yeah so
it'll be it'll be we'll we'll fill in
we'll fill in we'll be good so then yeah
so there'll be no fighting kit on
wednesday and then next week you come
back when i come back wednesday
the fall on wednesday
at what time i'll be in the morning so i
can so i won't be here but you could do
one maybe you jeff dyer whoever that's
what we'll do
you could do that yeah
yeah have fun in montana what are you
doing riding horses wrangling cattle
just riding horses shooting grizzly bear
pretend i'm on yellowstone bring some
berries oh bro how about uh you'll say
you know uh my son always wants to
either go in the hot tub or that's how
we end our day every day we always go in
the hot tub and he talks to me in the
hot tub so that's why i go in he taught
chatty kathy with only me so i always
make sure even though it's 100 degrees
out we're doing the hot tub
but he just chats in there but he puts
his hand on the you know we have a gate
because of a two-year-old so he can't
have an open pool
so my my tiger he's six he puts his hand
on the thing like whoa back get off he's
like what papa i'm like dude look
there's a [ __ ] i put on my ig story i
don't know if it's on my ig story is it
mark dude there's a black widow
big black widow now this is and i i just
saw that his underbelly and there's a
red you know
that's a thing no it no i looked into it
it's a brown widow they're actually
taking over a brown rook right there no
no they're called brown widows they're
actually taking over southern california
they're killing the black widows
so they're less they they think they're
less poisonous or less um
danger to humans okay but because they
don't put as much venom out but the
venom that they do is more toxic than
the black widow
which is interesting uh but that [ __ ]
thing and i i hate killing them i hate
killing animals ever since i was a kid
i'd never i don't kill them because i
have kiddos with because boston brothers
[Music]
i felt awful yeah
and big dude
and i and i'm getting i'm like i'm this
close and you know let's say the spiders
let's say the spider's there b i'm like
this close to my phone getting a picture
i'm putting my son in betting's crime
like what's wrong with you dude he said
i was thinking about it i think he got
too close to that black widow and i was
like nice now that you mentioned it i
probably did dude you're probably right
oh
there you go see can you go what happens
if you get bitten by a brown widow yeah
um uh simon brown was similar to the
most about paint site red mark
that although it's venom is as potent as
a black widow the brown widow probably
doesn't inject very much venom making it
less dangerous yeah but for a kid man
oh my friend i can't have it you can't
have it
no
wow you've heard of a brown widow wow
when i was out uh doing stuff with tim
kennedy they that the guy caught up uh
diamondback rattlesnake and brought it
out aren't they cool yeah man i was like
whoa they're badass looking uh-huh
nature wants you to know like don't [ __ ]
with them humans don't [ __ ] with and and
rattlesnakes out there have evolved to
not rattle because it gets them killed
how smart are they yeah like yeah on the
trails here when i see one i've seen one
for a while now there's so much traffic
but i still ride my bike all the time
they're almost the purple prism color
when they go across they're so dope
looking they look so beautiful animals
oh my god and the guy was like no we
don't kill him we just let him off and
which is great and they don't uh but
they're not they're not aggressive man
just don't [ __ ] with them no that's what
i said like the rouse things like i just
watch it go by goes into whatever the
other side of the freaking trail yeah
they're so dope looking oh yeah but that
that dude that that black widow that
brown widow there's no confusion
like i went my i go whoa i look at it
big butt it's like nicki minaj of
spiders big-ass butt
and then just the legs it doesn't look
like your normal house spider you know
right away don't [ __ ] with this thing
correct and the web because i had to
poke a stick out to get it out the web
was
dude the strongest spider web i've ever
felt in my life
i was like
strength to [ __ ] get through the web
yeah like your webs are different he
looks different they're bigger their
butts are fat they're doing re they have
they do a lot of stuff with spider webs
because they're so strong like if you
can if you can harness a thicker one
stronger than anything something crazy
yeah it's nuts [ __ ]
but yeah it's just the show but then the
we then on the basketball court we put
the balls probably a year or two ago i
reach in to get a ball and i see a big
ass black damn legit black damn yeah
i've seen that original black towels
dude so i i i go t i go back up back up
look at this dude the black little don't
touch it so i picked the ball up and
they're just chilling and then i set
them down and i put that black but i
took the ball and was like wishing to
get rid of this ball i [ __ ] threw it
as far as i could
hopefully it landed with him on the
upside yeah could land on the bottom
side but he his ass was fat
do you guys know where silk comes from
silkworms there you go
silk is also really strong little fact
about silkworms and silk in fourth grade
first day of school
i wore an all silk shirt which my aunt
nubby bought me with a bolo tie
baggy jeans and cowboy boots wow now wow
as a why don't we wear silk now i don't
know it's fine it feels so nice i mean
it's looking yeah especially in the
summer a short a like a short sleeve
with a collar yeah i have one from gucci
you do that's great silk shirt it's red
wow has a dope like skull with a snake
on the back yet looks like a fraction
no i worked to do all the promo for my
first special for showtime where
everywhere
and uh schultz made fun of me on i think
breakfast clubber uh
on his show he's like bro you look like
a cuban
salesman for cigars jay's shop just
showed me a picture of that actually he
was like this is what brendan wore and i
was like did you make him change it but
he looked really good like i don't know
why he was setting up a store he's like
i walked in and brenda was wearing this
yeah i'm like no i look cool but yeah
first day of fourth grade you know
predominantly black school did not go
well uh-huh
i got destroyed
didn't care
didn't care at all
yeah man yeah baltimore was [ __ ] the
best uh crab cake i've ever had damn
yeah crap now they're not giving crab
cakes away out there
everything would say market price and it
was on the season dude 32 for one crab
cake yeah
what 32 for 2 is 64. come again and i
was like what in the [ __ ] well i got to
try this right
it came with all the crab daddy it was
it made sense because if you're gonna
try that
oh dude it was like this and just full
of crap yeah oh
phenomenal oh yeah my girl that's her
favorite thing so she makes crab cake
and she has a house in delaware where
they well they get the blue dungeons
that's where they yes that's right daddy
they sh they literally catch crabs there
crab traps everywhere oh you know you
know who we saw in my hotel uh mr
baltimore uh carmelo anthony really he's
from there yeah really born and raised
and he was just hanging he was at the
hotel doing something i don't know i
don't know what he's doing there
massive man but he's from like the hood
of baltimore
[ __ ]
jay thought he was shoulder shorter but
i'm like no i saw him on the elbow he's
[ __ ] cute yeah yeah jay thought it
was me because you know i always wear
that pink hat and i have these shorts he
was wearing the exact same [ __ ] i was
jay's like brian brent i'm like you
thought i was carmelo anthony he's like
well he's fair skin i'm like are you out
of your mind he's damn near some foot
doll
seven yeah yeah that's what jay said
he's like six seven because i thought he
was more like six ten but yeah six seven
tops right top 20 basketball players top
50 20 is tough top 50 for sure but then
what's interesting about carmelo anthony
is you know how like kenya martin's sons
in the nba shaq's kids are you know
trying uh
dwyane wade's kid like everyone's older
now so their kids are playing
carmelo's anthony since probably the
biggest like prospect actually making
really freak freak super fast he's like
lebron james 15 year old is showing a
lot of promise from what i've seen
on instagram
yeah he's good here's the thing with
that he's good his dad's lebron james he
runs the nba right so
lebron's goal is to he's not going to
retire till he plays a game with his son
well if you own a team b right if your
team owner
think how many whether his son rides the
bench whatever let's in lebron go
whatever team drafts his son so if
you're that team let's say you're
the memphis grizzlies where you know in
a huge market and you know by draft and
lebron son lebron comes with it for once
even if it's one year sales
you're gonna sell it on the road off the
road and also just the merchandise you
make alone so i
he's not that good scottie pippinson i
think is better but because lebron's his
dad and lebron was like i'm not retired
i play a game with my son i bet someone
takes a shot on him but he's not that
carmelo's son's better do you know by
the time they're 15 now oh yeah they
know oh yeah yeah yeah they knew when
lebron was 13. they did yeah okay yeah
but there are labels that's why they
know they're a late bloomer oh yeah some
late bloomers like steph curry was late
bloomer yeah i think that jordan didn't
start playing basketball they were 16.
no no he got cut from his high school
basketball team
do you ever see in his you know his
speech i did he threw shade at the high
school incredible he goes you're wrong
weren't you and the guy's like the [ __ ]
yeah
but not really at the time i was like
what at the time you weren't he's like
[ __ ]
hilarious it's like watching usain bolt
when he ran his first olympics which i
didn't realize it was 2004 or something
and he came in
fifth sixth seventh i don't know what it
was sometimes it happens olympics yeah
and then get better come back they go
through the experience yeah it takes
some time strange right
now i i was talking to when we're up
because we saw carmel and then we got in
the car to go to uh the venue
and i was like you're kind of bouncing
me out kind of bumps around because
you're carmelo anthony play for the
lakers right now
you know he he he's the veteran minimum
right so it's a lot of money is
expensive
you can just hire a young guy to
probably do that he doesn't really play
defense anymore he used to be
dude when he played for the nuggets
remember that's when i came up so that's
why i mean jay loved the nuggets dude it
was this is the team
and they went to the western conference
finals it was carmelo anthony in his
prime averaging i know [ __ ] 30 points
a game baller allen iverson
allen iverson and not like not his prime
but [ __ ] good allen iverson kenyon
martin marcus camby dude i remember all
those guys bro their team was stacked it
was so much fun me and jay would do
anything to go the games it was so much
[ __ ] fun but that i remember carmelo
was that and obviously he went on to do
other things
with the knicks who's really [ __ ]
good and then with the portland
trailblazers kind of you know stayed in
the corner and shot threes and then with
the lakers they were just so goddamn old
but i was talking about damn like
thinking about being carmilla man think
about being carmilla
you meant because him and lebron went to
rival high schools they so it was
remember this this is the draft class
lebron carmel anthony chris bosh
dwyane wade
and uh i forget there's a european guy
at fifth there but
monsters
mom that was a draft class and they're
all like retired some so i was i got
kind of sad i told you
if if you're carmelo man think about
like the ride's overdue what a ride but
it's over yeah what do you do how long
do you play for him
hot second yeah because remember he only
played one year at seriously he won a
national championship then got drafted
the nba so one year in college then he's
in the nba stud too from the nuggets you
think about how good those [ __ ] guys
are to make it yeah the thing about six
seven yeah well 12 12 people they choose
right on a team 12
12 you have five play yeah well well i'd
say nine play because you mix in the
substitute so nine play yeah so out of
all the people in the world
worldwide sport yeah twelve twelve
people make it but the thing but my
thing is bombs man i think about think
about being carmelo since the age of 12
you've been this he's different lebron
because when lebron was like 13
you know they were giving him money his
mom's driving a [ __ ] hum or whatever
show up to school like that's
interesting but with carmella he wasn't
that kid grew up rough
super rough in the hood
but you're this you know everyone you
know bends at the knee for you and then
next you know he's 38 years old 39 how
old is criminal chin and and you know
what i'm saying like it's time to get
off the ride dude yeah man breaks my
heart it's over i remember look at him
you know who else
she's my age when did he retire he's not
retired yet he's not he's so he was born
a year after me he he hasn't retired he
was on the lakers i don't know what
they're going to do with him but he's
been in base since
2003 dude wow so was that 19 years wow
professional at the highest level for 19
years and before that you won a nash
championship at syracuse before that
your rival with lebron because they went
to one's oak hill and then there's the
other one you know what i'm saying damn
damn that's time to get off the ride
bubba yeah hey bob do you have fun 19
years yeah you're a league you can still
play though but you're so expensive
we're just gonna have a young guy do
your job time to get off the road damn
what do you do damn he's not an analyst
you know that's not his thing like
anything else all good things come to an
end and that's how it is yeah isn't a
bummer yeah but it's also part of you
you know who i felt heavy energy from
and i want to go hey man you all right
don't know him in any [ __ ] facet when
i went to the all-star game the home run
derby kevin durant was in his guy who
pays attention social media and has
burner accounts and gets a lot of cr
criticism he does why does he get
criticism
um just kind of you know because he went
he went he went to uh golden state so he
left oklahoma state which was piss
people then be off he goes to golden
state which you know they're stacked
they win a championship with him he
leaves you know which you know people
upset then he goes to brooklyn they're
stacked there they don't win there
and he pays attention to social media
like he got caught with the burner
account stuff like that
you can just feel like he's a guy who
talks about mental illness and
depression stuff i i could i could i was
looking i'm just like god probably they
wanted to say something about you oh so
bad i wanna make you all right man yeah
i know i'm not [ __ ] too this is my
perspective dude he's my favorite player
oh he is yeah i want to be like dude
it's all good i remember you saw a
special on him or something and you were
like how do you not love that guy uh
yeah maybe him yeah he's just a monster
monster so seven feet two right uh six
ten
what's one big do you captain durant
daddy yeah god you won't you won you won
you've won yeah doesn't matter what
happens yeah
i think the hardest thing in the world
is uh
like
just saying to yourself
you're better than you think you are
like don't be that hard on yourself yeah
you don't be arrogant about it but yeah
it's like
i'm such a dude i'm such a dick to
myself and and oh yeah that's that's why
she's really good you know you get to
you sometimes but most times like trust
me folks
you're not saying i'd say way things
worse to myself you think you're hard on
me
no that's how i feel i'm like whatever
you think i come come live in my head
[ __ ] yeah it's not [ __ ] yeah if you're
kevin durant's like come on dude get off
of there see my boy danny ricardo he
drives for mclaren he's on a rough time
such a rough time so there's two guys on
the team there's a young guy who's doing
better than him
they paid him i don't know 40 million to
race right they make all the money
there's only i don't know 24 in the
world
that's a huge [ __ ] sport he's one of
the 24
but he's you know he's having an off
year so i don't know that sport and jay
i'm i don't know that sport but i'm
close with danny he's a great guy he
doesn't know my sport i know his and it
just i didn't realize how big of a deal
he was and we're just friends he likes
bike riding like cars so we talked about
that
and how big of a deal was and then jay
whose balls deep in f1 was like hey you
know i think they're about to let danny
go like they can do that he's like yeah
if they're not performing they let him
go damn and he's getting like all this
criticism tonight so you know i don't
know what's going on his text i'm like
dude [ __ ] the noise stay the course man
like you'll he'll get picked up by
somebody else
that's
that's the name of the game
you know people think that when you're
at the top and you're making all the
money you've arrived it's sometimes
harder
because you can get toppled right quick
you just become a target especially in
sports yeah especially in sports yeah
yeah yeah i was watching those baseball
players i went to a dodgers game
and and
you know every one of those guys i mean
there are some all-stars but every one
of those guys if you don't if you're
really performing shitty you're going to
hear it from the fans and then you might
get
bounced back down to the oh yeah yeah
triple a double a yeah it's tough man
yeah tough gig fresh sports tough ski
it's like sam alvey who fought this
weekend
what's interesting i was one of his
coaches on uh ultimate fighter season 14
watch that fight he's lost nine in a row
i saw that nine in a row i i i i think
sam alvi that's a lot sam alvey is
taking punishment too he's game he takes
punishment takes late fights
he's not he's not he's not as athletic
as a lot of guys but also he thought
whoever that guy was was a
seasoned [ __ ] boxing wrestling
he was so good you could see his it was
just night and day night and day i don't
know who that where was he from do you
know
yeah some some easter block country
tough
tough gig good guy sam great guy yeah
seems like it
nine in a row is a lot
that's a lot
yeah just it all right it might not it's
from poland the guy five [ __ ] beast
yeah it might not be for you at that
level you know what i'm saying if that's
what it looked like yeah
the longest losing skit of all time the
fc he was tied with bj penn at eight
that's what it looks like nine it's not
it's just not yeah it's just
unfortunately it's just that level and
you know the ufc it's just not what they
do you're just not there
with those guys that's you're fighting
now it's international sport for right
real you got a guy like that from poland
who probably
studied under the russian boxing system
forever sure who the [ __ ] knows the
chance of him cracking the top 15 is one
in a million yes one million of
professional fighters you're dealing
with olympic wrestlers olympic boxers
you're dealing with all kinds of
high-level athletes now coming in who
are who have been doing this [ __ ]
forever yeah you know
so
right i mean
i mean
yes no i mean
yeah yeah yeah you're right now you're
right you're right yeah i'm not gonna
argue that you're right you're dealing
with these these daghestanis who their
only way out ladies and gentlemen their
only way out is fighting when you're
inside a way out but to me i won't even
say way out because a lot of them love
you know
uh dagestan stuff like that but it's all
that's what they do like we play
baseball and basketball football they
fight also i went to top team and i was
with thiago and and dustin poirier and
those guys and i was looking at all the
people that that
get to come in because they get
applications everybody wants to be there
but the people that get to even be there
are all these russian polish they're
from all over the world and they're the
best when they're the best the best in
their city yeah they're all regional
champions yes or they're olympic
wrestlers or something they were a lot
of bunches they can't put it together
yeah yeah and now they're there with
their work ethic with their coaching
staff with all that that's only gonna
get worse b we're like
still in leather football helmets go get
to the nfl bubba get to the nfl and you
look around you're
oh you're not even gonna make the team
and you were all american at division
one
i was just a guy
what and you're not gonna make the team
it's so you know everyone's
superstars
superstars and some won't make the team
yes it's the most so what i do is i
watch i watch some of those practice
drills i watch some of those guys who
are
kind of trying to make the team when
they're doing like they're they're off
the line they got a linebacker and a
receiver coming at each other oh wait
what practice i thought you were talking
about no in the nfl these are these guys
who are oh yeah and you see the
difference between the guys who are the
all-stars or the guys and then the other
guy who's a [ __ ] beast but just ain't
good enough
just ain't good enough no you you look
at it like that that margin for error is
so weird no you look at like donald
aaron donald for the rams you're like oh
he's a [ __ ] king freak
for 290 shredded yeah shred with the
fastest first step hold on
ever in the nfl
is that true ever yeah that's why he's
so good yeah so yeah he got voted
unanimously around league is the best
player in the league he's that dominant
that's so weird yeah cool yeah i love
that greatness [ __ ] so why
so what
you're just some guy in the world
step on the the nfl field you're just
some guy what'd you say about high
school what'd you see around the 40 and
what'd you say well b why do you think
when your buddies went you can't handle
it when the guy goes i would have went
then i fell in like
no
hold on you didn't go to college no okay
oh yeah well that's that's the crazy
evening
so even if you threw for 10 000 yards in
the nfl which never did but even if you
did in college
even then your chances of making it over
here is not good and you know why you
say that you dean because because the
evidence backs you up i've just i've
been behind the curtain i've seen it
it's like oh i'm i don't belong here but
you can just watch hard knocks go watch
those guys but that's that's
that's dramatic they follow a guy who
they know is not gonna make you break
your heart but
there's worse things than that for sure
they don't show the way coaches talk
really about the players in the way they
talk to them they can't show that they
break your heart right
because you're a horse you're you're oh
don't give a [ __ ] about horse you're a
racehorse
i'll put you down look look at lamar
jackson for the baltimore ravens guys
had mvp season ballin even they're like
no he just proved it one more year
excuse me he went mvp two years ago we
know where he's gonna get hurt or
something like that we're not ready to
invest in him excuse me well the guy who
caught the the
when paid uh eli manning threw that ball
with that tyree david tyree and he got
caught the next season yeah i was like
what thanks for the super bowl thanks
for the football win hold on thanks for
catching it off that guy's helmet which
one the greatest catch all the time yeah
we appreciate it
he's like why i'm in the office what's
funny mention that we're gonna we're
gonna fire you
up but just a few months ago i've won us
a super aw no we know plaxico burst when
he caught he was this killer in in in
and then he shoots himself in the thigh
and they're like you know what overall
we just
you got to get out of here it's just too
much
now think how good like a guy like
deshawn watson is with all these
allegations oh my god they're like right
now the cleveland browns go no we know
it's awful it's awful we're gonna
guarantee him the highest money ever
about 250 million is that cool with
everybody
yeah but he's gonna sit out for a year
we know that's probably gonna happen or
the the six months cool cool six games
cool cool he's that good we're gonna
risk it
even dude this is professional sports in
a nutshell
even when aaron rodgers was accused of
double murder
rogers no i'm sorry aaron uh hernandez
yeah before he killed himself even when
aaron hernandez was accused of double
murder they thought he was gonna get off
there was rumors that the patriots or
the raiders were still gonna sign him
when he got out
yeah
because they're so rare
because he's a freak
there's a guy
uh oh [ __ ] uh
percy harvin played for the yeah i know
played for the fourth place played at
ohio state no no florida gators would
tell him okay that's right yeah timmy
told me under uh urban meyer yep there's
robin said they did the best aaron
hernandez aaron hernandez you had the
pouncey brothers you had tebow stack
stack you had percy harvin
briggy harvin was so talented
wouldn't show up for
weeks at practice
they didn't kick him off the team
he would miss practices would miss the
team flight to the games the boosters
would charter him out like you know what
i do feel like playing like cool chart
him out there and he'd ball out without
playing
this continues in the nfl he said his
headache was so bad he got out of
practice he didn't play all year then
they went hey percy it's the super bowl
do you mind playing super he goes i
guess
didn't play for months oh this is the
level you're dealing with didn't play
for months
they kick off to him he hasn't touched a
football in months brian they kick after
him he returns it for a touchdown can
you bring percy harbin up i want to see
what he i want to see just what he looks
like
[ __ ] man
did he what's he doing now like what
what
i have no clue
is that him
yeah tim uh yep that's him yeah well
there he is
he's kind of muscular struggles with uh
uh depression a lot of stuff yeah
but just a
genuine freak
across the board i know people tell me
he's the biggest freak
that's him look at this
yeah
and just couldn't but just couldn't put
it together because had
problems with
mental you know especially back then
receiver wide running back receiver like
slot receiver
kickoff return specialist
jesus
freaking made a lot of money
i don't know i don't know
interesting right how long do you play
for it not long no he played for a while
bounced around a little bit yeah
now four four one in the 40.
yeah
yeah he's drafting the first round
hmm
that's how good he is
they won't we'll take a shot off retired
in 2016. he had migraines tired of being
in pain from migraine headaches yeah
yeah because he always complained about
migraines
he
you can understand that you don't want
to be hitting your head with a migraine
that's impossible to deal with
wow funny right all right jim what do
you got
all right first one's pretty scary but
awesome
oh
have you guys seen this video yet no i
haven't seen it this pair he's it's
considered an acro paraglider so they do
like stunts and stuff like that but his
parachute wrapped around him
and in the last minute he was able to
get out so i'll show you real quick
[Music]
oh no
that's so scary look at this look at
this look at this
you're falling through the air and
you're tangled up
[Music]
so he's taking open all that parachute
cord parachute
so it's he's just free falling right now
yes he is
oh he's getting close look how close
that is
he barely made it
got it
[Music]
still not a this guy put the epitome of
calm under pressure not your time
brother what was divine intervention of
saving your own life um oh my lord
oh it's divine accidents happening god's
not making you jump out of the plane i
think it's him being you know
experienced yes staying calm calm being
calm is the main thing
you know what to do that's right
yeah i wouldn't
this is
so alex jones was on trial um he he did
take
he did say that okay the attack on sandy
hook was 100 real but then now he's
ordered to pay 49.3 million dollars to
the families here's what's inside about
him at the i don't know if you guys know
about this about alex jones even when he
was banned when we got banned from all
platforms even then he's making
800 000 a day off his platform he's got
a lot of money a lot but he you know
they're like oh because they found out
that oh you claim you're bankrupt
it's different like there's mz hammer
donald trump bankrupt and alex jones
bankrupt he's like no i'm bankrupt you
can't pay this but then they look into
the finances like oh bob because they
had a forensic
economist forensic investigators and it
showed that he has like around 270 mil
yes crazy he's the face of you know
conspiracy theories think how interested
people are in all that yeah around the
world and then also think also think
about is with alex jones
you know
he's a complicated dude right and i
you know i've met alex jones he was nice
to me i like him but
if i'm one of those parents my child is
killing that dude you i think i'm mad
you'd be at him saying it was fake this
was staged these aren't real they got
they got harassed i would fight him i
would strangely fight him but also you
know 50 million dollars well my my thing
is that he he can't afford it he will
afford it and then what will happen is
he will go on to become even bigger
maybe maybe
if you're alex jones fan you better hope
i don't know if he's bigger that might
be the height i don't know if he's
bigger because clearly he lied on the
stand he purged himself you can see it
did you see that yeah did you see that i
said you gave us two years your lawyer
gave us two years but did you see the
lawyer [ __ ] up and accidentally sent
them sentences yeah two two years yes
two years they can use to the other
lawyers yeah that's fiction
no on accident it looks it looks on
purpose i i got skeptics when i read
them like oh clearly it looks like the
lord somebody did alex jones uh or
someone paid him off easily
yeah he's in a little bit of trouble huh
yeah yeah but i don't know is there
anything about the perjury or no he's i
guess he just pays 50 million well now
they're looking into the january 6
commission was such a waste of time hate
democrats move on we have bigger fish to
fry
yeah there's like multiple charts so
this is like one of them there's like he
has like three more or something has to
go in court with so who knows how much
he's gonna owe in the very end what
what's weird is that so i don't mean
yeah what's weird is how you know
obviously rogan defends alex jones but
roman does say yeah he made a mistake he
makes a lot of mistakes he says a lot of
things right he's like that's the
problem a broken clock
is right twice a day right you could
that's that's what i would be doing
like he was talking but yeah yes and no
right because if you're saying you know
with his stuff like he was talking about
uh epstein island
10 years ago he's like oh there's an
island where they go and they have
famous people go there and then
compromise not hook up with underage
girls and it's like you're out of your
mind that's that's probably true right
that's true no i'm telling you yeah
rogan brought it up rogan goes you need
to have someone create a clip of all the
[ __ ] you got right for
throughout all the years yeah because
he's like you've got more right than
you've gotten wrong but the stuff he's
gotten wrong he's gotten wrong wrong no
that's that's interesting i i do think
that that's probably one of the reasons
he's so [ __ ] successful
uh because oh there wouldn't be if he if
he was wrong all the time he could only
be wrong for long for people all right
we're out dude
no he's got some very strong followers
and i'm not i i i have to be careful
about criticizing him because i don't
know enough about what i don't follow
him i like alex jones i hate this his
sandy hook that's the thing that's
that's what that's what because kids
that's right so those parents i'm like
yeah pay them yeah but then
go back to work yeah because i like his
work so it's interesting that's where he
lost i think you need i think you need
people like shows i think you need
outliers i think people that push
against the fringe i think he's great
and and you're the face of it of course
he's making money i feel like he's
entertaining i just think that people
who lend a voice to misinformation and
mal information and disinformation are
the problem and he could be considered
one of those people under certain
circumstances so that's fair yeah no
he's definitely not
you know
you it's okay to criticize them you know
but also in his business you're gonna
take some shots dude you are it'd be
like this though there's so i think you
have to become to the distinction so
youtube you could say youtube censors me
or you could say youtube prioritizes
certain things over the other thing now
the question is is that censorship or is
that just youtube prioritizing
one thing over here over the other and
there is a distinction and and you have
to kind of be specific about it so one
could be censorship as in they they're
stopping it from being seen or are they
just prioritizing this for x y and z
reasons the problem is they've shut down
things that they just think is
misinformation where they're not
scientists they're not so they would say
nope this doesn't agree with our agenda
you're shut down and that's where i have
a problem yeah because you don't know
hold on that's misinformation but this
isn't right well to me you like you're
that's not your job no
i'm fine with misinformation people
saying sandy hook's fake which we know
it's not because there's parents
grieving and then there's a difference
between when the pandemic started and
people said this or people said this and
you decide because you align with this
publicly right can i say the latest tim
dillon show us this guy curtis yarvin as
a guest super smart computer scientist
guy and he broke down
some of the
reasons that we have these issues with
misinformation in a way that's better
than almost anything on the side of
new york times
harvard and all these things where the
sort of you know the academic industrial
complex are all in alignment because of
the interest behind it like you know we
have this sort of like expert
bureaucracy
and when it benefits them to do
something they're going to be well see
like the new york times set up see the
harvard setup they're all working
essentially in conjunction because they
have the same interests of like
self-interested elites that's a bunch of
money yeah that's a but that's a problem
when new york times and you know l.a
youtube's amongst those things right yes
they're all on the same side the left or
whatever far left and they're you know
they have an agenda to push well that's
that what are we doing yeah yeah yeah
but we have here is like well harvard
said it well new york time said it but
why are they saying it yeah yeah they
all you're all in the same same pool
yeah it's not good no
no they didn't be neutral
on both sides i don't there's some don't
get twisted there's misinformation on
the right and left yeah yeah both sides
and they should be in charge of that
when it's left or right
but you can't just say oh the right
hand's missing right it's harder
that's insane right
correct but you know uh instagram like
well meta because uh facebook aka betta
owns instagram and they're being sued by
parents whose ch children like teens
have committed suicide
because now they used to be protected by
this behind this law where social media
isn't responsible for third party
content
that doesn't work anymore because kids
are committed suicide and because yeah
they can't be responsible for what the
third parties put out but they are
responsible for creating an algorithm
that let's say you're looking up suicide
it keeps every morning showing you other
likes of suicide suicide so this girl
who's like 14
was
she you know she was mad depressive like
had really bad depression she looked up
a video of this lady hanging herself
with a belt
and then by looking that up
meta goes let's show her this all the
time yeah now that's not a third party
thing yeah that's the algorithm that
they've create so every day she's waking
up seeing it's on in her face in her
face what does she do a few months later
kills herself the exact same way that
she was shown on social media i got a so
now there's several people that have
done that and now they're suing meta and
they're saying it's the biggest case
they've ever had to fight because
they've been able to hide behind this
wall it doesn't work in this your
algorithm it's pushed around right ai
radicalization right that's that's the
thing about this [ __ ] it's creating
monsters that we're not even aware of
and you know 14 we're aware of it now
because there's been some whistleblowers
who worked on real no they they were
very aware this algorithm was hurting
kids but they decided to get proceeds
over
taking care of the health yeah so that
so
what we we need with children especially
i have really young children what we
need is that
case to come to light and they win so
meta is forced to change their algorithm
so that doesn't happen in the future
because if they can keep doing it and
the law protects them we're [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] two dads two [ __ ] two dads two
dads two [ __ ]
you give all the [ __ ] when you got kids
all the [ __ ] that's that's the title we
use that's dude yeah so brittany griner
were sentenced to nine years in prison
in russia
i love elon musk's take on this
what's this elon
he goes everybody's up in arms about
brittany granny goes we have people
hundreds of people in america that are
in prison for the same offense he was
where's where's the energy when it comes
to them
he's we're just gonna be upset about
brittany grant she's good at basketball
there's people here in america that
we're mistreating that are you know
because of weed offenses
and then kamala harris like oh let's get
her out it's like hold on you know how
many people you put in prison due to
weed yeah and and then would use them as
slave labor and hold on and now you want
to say get brittany grinder out yeah
you're out of your [ __ ] mind correct
also tack two more years on to brittany
griner because she said she could be the
male nba player so
russia attacked two more years off is
that true yeah yeah
said she could be like a famous one
what yeah get out of your mind she might
have just been talking to her no no no
she has a very deep voice she's very you
know what's interesting have you seen
who they want to trade who we have that
guy he's the death arm dealer the the
arm dealer of death
like you and trump elon were like whoa
whoa whoa this ain't a fair trade man
this guy's a real [ __ ] problem
yeah the merchant of death that's right
have you seen him have you looked into
him yeah dude we can't let that guy go
terrible guy yeah [ __ ] terrible guy
provided weapons for like the worst
atrocities in africa horrible horrible
he's a bad bad dude oh my god it's not a
fair trade
but if you're russia she's just a pawn
in the game dude
you want to talk about bad timing
the worst timing in the history of
professional rights
correct
just russia decides to go to war with
ukraine and have issues with america and
you want to try and sneak illegal drugs
into russia because you thought you were
safe by the oligarch oh
daddy's one of the things you can't see
awful i think she'll get off though
right i mean won't they which what we're
really i bet we trade the arms dealer
for her
well
that's not a good trade but i think
there's got to be something we can do
well here's the other thing to be fair
though they do have a military person
over there that they're going to release
the military person which is amal of
four and brittany grant brittany grant
is most famous but no one's talking
about the other person so we'll release
the merchant of death for the the the
veteran and brittany graham no one's
talking about the veteran who's get
released he's over there for whatever
reason
okay that's good trade yeah i guess i
don't know that merchant sounds awful
yeah merchant of death terrible what
terrible but russia you know
for them it's just a game
what's this now
i had a friend who was a paramedic and
he said that when he used to go to old
people's homes you know old people would
die lonely and then you never discover
him for like two weeks or whatever right
when he'd go and they'd break in the
house if the person had a dog the dog
would starve to death next to the the
party but if the person had a cat the
cat would eat facts
i'll tell you why i had a friend
paramedic so that's why
me and him are on the exact same
wavelength i love this guy it's the best
thing he said all day
if the person had a dog the dog would
starve to death next to the body but if
the person had a cat the cat would eat
him
the comment the person goes i don't mind
the cat needs it more than me i'm dead i
want the cat to starve i've loved that
cat eat my ass yeah i've heard that
though yeah i've heard that multiple
times i've never been a fan of cats no
so this clip has been going around would
you do this is my question
i guess this guy was celebrating his
divorce by doing this the answer is i
would not
there's something it looks like what if
you broke your leg and then you just
have to keep falling did he break his
leg no i'm just saying what if what if
you're injured yourself and then you get
lost 40 feet long that's
that's uh i don't [ __ ] with those rides
don't think you're supposed to do that
is that alex jones today alex jones is
after he is
celebrating not paying 40 million yeah
celebrating
dude why did he jump off the top down
they're not good tits no not the tits i
want to see no
there was one that brendan said with the
uh body modification oh my god do you
see that person it's insane is it on
here no yeah at the top of the original
email i sent i think
wait what is that oh there it is there
we go right here click on this
you can probably play a video with no
volume but look at this person
wait what body modification fanatic go
up chin oh you could probably play the
video it's from music you know what down
the middle
[Music]
[Music]
the full interview is on renee ponte's
youtube channel you can find him as
renee zz if you're a fan of the black
alien project i highly recommend you go
watch this interview it's fantastic so
what did he do he's trying to amputate
one of his legs and split his penis in
half but why take the leg off aliens
have one leg
good that's a great question because he
is
out of his
yeah because he is actually says
tattooed man who plans to become a black
alien okay dicey one hand turned into a
claw now wants one of his legs amputated
he's also announced on his black alien
project instagram page his next
operation will be splitting his penis
into two again uh that he's still 44
of his way of gold becoming a black
alien now listen
we don't know what a black alien looks
like we've never met it and i'm not sure
they have one leg and split their dicks
that's what before you do this let's
just get confirmation these black guys
do this go to his instagram chin black
alien players out of his [ __ ] yeah
that's body dysmorphia in a way yeah i
mean uh it's beyond that can you imagine
seeing that thing in the street
no i would lose my [ __ ]
yeah
black alien project there it is
certified whoops wrong one
oh my lord oh my lord
oh my god
i like that he's posing for cool
instagram pics you know
oh he split his tongue
yeah
and his nose
tells you to do his nose and his fingers
oh he put a claw he got a surgery so he
has a claw yeah so he amputated those
two fingers in yep what a crazy person
what doctor's doing this yeah well i
guess freedom of choice i guess
but yeah some doctors would definitely
object to that on ethical issues on
ethical grounds i think you're you're
not even allowed to do it right
it has to be underground
here's a question for you oh my god
here's a question freebie oh yeah big
alien dick say that right now
get that big lizard dick sticking out
the front brian out in the christmas way
yeah does this guy get chicks
i don't know i'm sure there's always
somebody out there who's interested in
some crazy [ __ ]
do you think about waking up in the
morning next to that yeah i don't know
what's he doing i don't know is this a
big day he just wants to be an alien
even aliens you really wanted to piss
off your dad you know oh my god dude
even aliens are like what in the [ __ ]
amy's like we don't look like this
oh he wants to put his dick in too yeah
he's just interested in creating the
most horrific look he can possibly
create
people will take pictures with him
that's not i'm assuming he really
started off as a white guy yeah i'm
assuming he's hanging he's not long for
this
world i don't know yeah that's fair
brian i i just don't is that originally
yeah what a good looking guy
what a good looking guy but what a mess
wow
good look that's how it started
some guy said he did all this to hide
that he's gay
[Laughter]
look at that that is so insane
i mean you did to yourself if it makes
him happy though yeah
how does his mother he's not happy he's
happy oh you say this stuff listen to me
happy birthday he's not happy okay this
is a guy who has
full-blown neurosis like full-blown
sight this is a psychotic
this is an insane psychotic it's just a
person chin and brown i would assume uh
his relationship with his mother and
father is not great he's just
a limb here some people are
genuinely out of their mind and that's
an example and if that's not completely
out of your mind if that's not
completely mentally
what do you think is right then
this is uh
oh this is somebody who can he cut into
his head he's killing himself he's he's
he's
he's
trying to deform now here's one thing
i'm jealous of i bet he breathes so got
him well
oh my goodness
i bet he breathes so [ __ ]
his face oh
oh sir it's a disaster as they say in
french does that does that so sad man
it's really him there
look at him look what he did to himself
all right is this 100 real though you
guys think oh yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right that's a good question oh 100
how would it not be real yeah what do
you think he's using photoshop
everything is makeup yeah i don't know
oh no not the nose no i mean
like he it looks like a baby what about
the fingers i don't know we've seen this
stuff on instagram before though
remember that i've never seen
it something oh come on you might be
dealing with a mask
no no i might be dealing with the mask
not the lips no no the lips and the nose
their heads all the time and also you
can get those things inserted into your
skull people have done all the time no
they definitely do that but his face is
like i can't watch this anymore it makes
me sad his face is what
it looks like there's a lot of layers on
top of it makes me sad man
yeah they have implants under the skin
yes i've seen those two before i think
he's 100
i really hope you're right okay i hope
you're [ __ ] right
um i thought the logan paul wwe stuff
was pretty that's insane see this
clip was this this logan paul's debut on
the wwe i was kind of impressive um oh
he's an athletic kid yeah so he's
twisting his kids athletic [ __ ]
all the way to the outside
wasting no time
and apparently this earned him and
that's the miz he's doing against
apparently this uh earned him a lot of
like credit with the wwe fans yeah like
he's going above and beyond that's not
cheap with the backflips
that's not easy dude listen to the crowd
at the start they weren't into it
amazing that's the thing about logan
palmer once they're in it what you know
once he's involved something he's he's
undeniable 100
please check that one out
did you guys see this on francis and
gano's instagram page this was a real
post that he made advertising his jiu
jitsu academy
some people had some questions
um
well
that is not how you do that
i'm not watching this and the caption is
uh i'm turning my head you know
three different ways get better at
advertising because i can't look at this
i'm not gonna look my boy austin wake
he goes he's on showing off five
different ways to stack your opponent
and they say stack too yeah
francis and ghana was probably not the
guy to have a five different ways to get
my ass eaten
right now
that's the worst
like yeah what the hell he should have
made a joke like hey ladies who's
interested in coming my jitsu cat you
know something this is wow that was
weird i thought it was like a mcdojo
life post at first where there's an
actual academy yeah looking like oh
francis gotta actually post it
yeah okay
cool yeah i'll be god bless him probably
open that up in africa or something like
that and i'm sure there's not a lot of
jiu-jitsu schools there but also do a
striking gym right yeah no one likes it
franco i want to learn his channel
we did this yeah
yeah this one
the is quoted tate
i find it offensive that police officer
in england will stop me for speeding and
then refuse to take a bribe and pretend
that
no no no i'll tell you why because he'll
sit there and go no this is the law law
and order and pretend that the law means
something and and [ __ ] me over but if
you're a billionaire or if you're boris
johnson you can go to epstein's island
you can [ __ ] throw parties during
covid you know the [ __ ] you want right
so the whole the whole idea of law and
order is a lie i find it offensive
yeah so yeah he's some wiggle room that
he goes i like living in corrupt
countries because everybody can play
yeah
i see what he's saying not just the
elite yeah
brock used my quote the other day yeah
the rock did use your quote the rock if
you're watching i hope you heard that
and didn't remember andrew's name but i
think you must have hey i heard this
quote the other day but i'm not sure
where from then he directly quoted you
come on rock band come on dwayne doesn't
matter
it's cool i heard this quote the other
day that i want to share with you guys
i'm paraphrasing here but it goes like
this the person who goes to the gym
every single day regardless of how they
feel will always beat the person who
goes to the gym when they feel like
going to the gym the man who goes to the
gym every single day regardless of how
he feels will always beat the man who
goes to the gym when he feels like going
to the gym
hustlers university
he's such a character he's awesome i
love him
about that yeah is that it well we did
it again brennan we did it man you
didn't came back you need me i'll be in
tahiti
oh that's right
who can guide me through smart
but i want you guys to know you made a
shrimp trip and you're okay and i made
it back live from baltimore august 18th
i will be in salt lake city for one
night just one night one night papa i'm
going out to annie stump's wedding my
buddy's wedding oh nice yeah in utah
montana but utah for salt lake is where
i you know stop off yeah i'll do salt
lake city i'll do wise guys one night
one show or two shows one show maybe two
it depends how we sell but right now
it's one show i bet you do two there
buddy i hope so yeah nashville tennessee
zany's august 26 27 yes some good dates
coming up san jose california improv
september 15
17. we got specan washington
comedy club september 22 24.
and uh we'll take it from there yeah we
got a busy september uh next up for me
one night only august 26th at the den
theater once you're only at 7 30 with
the thick boys squad
that is one night downtown chicago den
theater
because on the 27th reason why i'm in
chicago on the 27th we have the tough
mudder the thick mudder the heat is at
11 a.m go to toughmutter.com it is
selling out get tickets right now use
promo code team brendan you save 10 off
when you sign up there use that promo
code so the tough mudder in chicago is
on the 27th my comedy show at the den
theater on the 26th the friday right
before that we have shauban friends
august 31st big boys show august 31st at
the hollywood improv uh then uh
september gets
thick we have appleton wisconsin that
thing's almost sold out september 8th
through the 10th is appleton wisconsin
ontario improv my favorite clubs ontario
improv california ontario uh that's
september 15th or 17th and then boston
laugh boston your boy's gonna spend some
time in boston laugh boston september
29th through october 1st get your
tickets at thickboy.com or
f-a-t-k-z.com for brian and myself is
that it buddy that's it pal all right
kids love you this the fire kid we're
out